hi I'm jasmine whitbread on the chief
exec save children international and I'm
answering a question from and I will
face submitted Facebook please tell us
what you care about what future
direction you seek and how you'll
contribute to improving the state of the
world what passes you might imagine I
care about saving children's lives I'm
really outraged that this day and age
there's still a child dying somewhere in
the world completely preventable causes
every four seconds now that's the
shocker but the great news is it doesn't
have to be like that those numbers are
in fact coming down not as fast as we'd
like but these are simple solutions that
can save children's lives things like
getting vaccinated getting a community
health worker within reach of every
child and making sure they have the
basic nutrition that they need to avoid
becoming amount malnourished which is a
third of all those deaths are caused
because of underlying problems with with
not having the right food to eat and
what I'm excited about here at Davos is
that more and more people are getting
behind the need to address these bigger
issues in the world so yeah those do
data crisis and the economy and business
challenges but I think particularly the
next generation is not there not see
themselves see the business leaders or
NGO leaders or social entrepreneurs are
saying these are issues that are linking
her about that I am to see you addressed
in my lifetime off and they're coming on
board and they're pushing business
leaders to ask a question what is what
is business for deloitte's here did a
study for their Millennials and ask them
what's the primary purpose of business
and the answer came back about improving
social good in the world and then they
asked their top leaders and the arts
came back it's about profit and I really
hear that everywhere here in the
corridors there's a lot of debate about
what this business falls and you've got
organizations like unity so I guess come
from a launch of their partnership would
save it rather than others to reach a
million people and improve their lives
so they're coming on board with our
campaign to save children's lives and we
won't achieve these big changes unless
everybody gets involved all around the
world which in poor countries and I see
young people really driving that
conversion so that's what I'm excited
about is what I care about and what I
really believe it in terms of change
that's possible in our lifetime